Greg Fitzsimmons let us just join us
what's going on man what's going on
brothers have you been on but I've never
no actually in LA I think I did you show
up first LA trip yeah yeah you did right
you guys are so much younger than yeah
yeah yeah it's depressing really taking
a toll it's something about this age
what are you about to be 50 in July
yeah something happens to [ __ ]
Callaghan or whatever it is in your face
you just start [ __ ] it out it goes
away you become an apple core like an
old apple core humiliating yeah neck
skin and it doesn't matter how youthful
at heart you are now it shows in the
face I still feel young do you still
feel yeah it's a childish life I don't
have a mature life so yeah you do to a
certain degree but then you know you go
to shave and you look yep I'm a lot
[ __ ] old i time my shaves if i have
to like do a big show or whatever i
don't want to shave that day because
it's like putting a spotlight on the
gross play-doh [ __ ] that is my chin like
little jowls are dropping down it's like
no yeah so a couple days growth is
almost like a chick wearing makeup yeah
a little something to cover it up yeah
do you where I put like I'm such a
[ __ ] old lady I put lotion I [ __ ]
lotion the [ __ ] on my face and neck I'm
fighting it yeah I might buy myself two
more years of looking human why don't ya
I mean I've been using lotion forever
well okay I mean like high-end lotion
Sun encouraging yeah yes skin suta khals
yeah my friend's wife turned me on to it
she says it's like it's not the fancy
name but it's really good so I love it I
used the Avon lotion it's the best it's
just simple you know easy my friend used
to when he jerked off he would rub it in
his hair and he said that that won't
come is coming his hair he said that
that was the best conditioner you could
use I never heard that yeah maybe you're
just trying to get you to put calming
your hair yeah we were in the shower
trust me when I tell you what an
antisocial boy your friend was becoming
his own hair
also if you want to get rid of all
cavities feces in your mouth is how you
get rid of your cavity it's really good
for your gums yeah and if you piss on
your feet here at athlete's foot that's
better that's actually true yeah that is
true isn't it something in the urine
party acidity I'm gonna guess the
acidity I don't know I feel like people
just do disgusting things and try to
justify it yeah what is wrong with
people you know why would you yeah
there's cream for athlete's foot you
don't have to piss all over your feet if
you're a jock itch know I've had my
balls a [ __ ] but never a chronically no
my balls don't sweat much they're not
very big like laying against the side of
your thumb no very rarely sometimes they
do but not they're usually not my balls
don't usually don't stink and they're
not big they don't stick how do you know
if they don't stink I've done the tests
come on who hasn't tested you mean you
rub your finger on it oh my god yeah and
enough girls are suck my dick were there
like Jim Jim has a Jim has a specific
thing he said if I'm gonna if you were
gonna keep your balls fresh for me I'm
gonna keep my balls fresh you he says
that to all of his every woman I've tell
that to ya the ball smell good and sole
mine so let's get you in New York man
I'm writing on crashing I was I did it
last year and I'm doing again this year
it's a show on HBO yeah I'm doing very
well it's doing good it's the third
season and it's like kind of like a
well-oiled machine at this point we take
over the cellar a lot with Hank which I
think pisses off some comedians no I
just know that I'm when I'm when I'm
walking in the cellar because I just I
don't even check with our spots I'm
walking in the cellar and I see [ __ ]
a craft truck I'm like alright well I
guess it's the village underground yeah
I [ __ ] up again yeah yeah we come in
you know it's Judd Apatow show and he
loves the cellar and the underground and
him and Esther you're really close so we
end up I always feel bad because we'll
go in there for like two nights in a row
and and we just shoot stuff on stage and
shoot stuff it's very much about you
know that culture and the ball busting
you know if you've been on crashing yeah
I've had one minute and crashing in
season one Jesus what's I don't
no I don't know no your name comes up
all the time aren't you talking about
comics it's just it's just so your
writer so [ __ ] here's a writer and
you're asking him why yeah yeah yeah I
would love yeah all right good let's get
you on there yeah I'll come in there and
do whatever they whatever they ask I
think it's gonna happen Jim really is
non-committal well it's uh you know it's
about him struggling and a lot of times
it's the lesser-known comics that do it
I didn't know Pete coming up
I met him years later in the business so
I did yeah and when he was coming up
what are you guys at that spot now where
you're going into your third season
shows really successful but now you have
to figure out how do we do enough
movement so the show stays interesting
without doing so much movement that
we've told the story and he's now a
successful comedian and we've got no
place to go yeah now that's a good point
because your dear this is a trajectory
to the character but I wonder like how
many seasons can you do of a guy who's
breaking in but I think the way we do it
is it's very specific stories within it
you know and there's romantic interests
and there's there's be stories it's not
all just about his career because the
first season he was crashing with other
people right but at some point he should
have been working long enough that he
can get his own apartment
although that that absolutely could go
on for a few years you know guys who
don't take a long time to make money man
I took years to make [ __ ] money yeah
you could have five or six you weren't
that good though is there well yeah that
that is the asterisk stand with you and
I say this all the time about Jim and
and there's other people that I talk
about like I think you know Gaffigan
even founder came in he says we were the
same class you and I came up at the same
time in New York and you there were guys
that all of a sudden popped and just
started getting work all the time and
you were not part of that class no you
took a while yeah and you always were
who you were but I think you just you
just started owning it more and more and
more and then all of a sudden people
were like what the [ __ ] is going on with
Norton like you just kind of exploded
and people recognized it and you know it
all just kept feeding itself but there
was you you took
yeah it did it didn't happen right were
you aware of that at the time like that
that this was happening for other people
and it wasn't happening for you and did
it give you like that chip on your
shoulder where your um I never got a
chip on my shoulder no what's that of
course I had to I I never uh I I never
got bitter about no I didn't I didn't
know you never seen bitter bad yeah I
mean I always worked I mean I would go
on the road and do gigs I was having fun
but you wouldn't look a while yeah I
loved it I I wanted to be a comedian I
loved it so your expectations were low
going in so you were like the fact that
I'm making a living at all is a win no
you always want it like you always see
yourself doing well someday but I I said
I'll know I'm famous and I'll know I've
made it when I sign an autograph in New
York and then I sign one in Seattle like
that that to me will be like okay you've
made them like the whole country knows
and I've had that happen where you
signed something newer and up means
nothing yeah it means nothing right I
don't feel any more famous than I did is
amazing you make those goals and you
realize we young yeah and then you hit
them but you you know there's no feeling
of accomplishment cuz now you're just
thinking you've been making goals the
entire time but it's good though cuz it
always makes you move more like you know
HBO special or whatever yeah the Tonight
Show or let him and you do those things
and you're like okay those are great but
that's not the end that's just a nice
thing yeah I mean for me it was I think
for a lot of us Letterman was everything
when we were coming up and when I got it
it was like the greatest [ __ ] moment
of my life
you know Bar None it was like everything
I heard would be and I got off stage and
my father had just died before that and
I was very close to him and my last
thought before I went out was I talked
to my dad just quick sure talk to my dad
and I went out had the set of my life
Letterman loved it I walk off in faith
Hill is standing there she's she's going
on it what the [ __ ] she's going on after
before and I just start crying like a
[ __ ] little girl I just start crying
and she puts her arms around me that's
nice yeah Wow it's never been as good
that was it like I've had obviously I've
been doing it for 29 years read plenty
of things happen since then nothing is
even in the bowl
kind of completed something like that
way hey this is what I want and all its
rare like whether it is there's always
something that goes wrong and when you
get everything you want and it's in that
moment and here's everything you wanted
it's overwhelming and it's all the
emotions coming together all at once
yeah but yeah they have to right you're
like okay the worst is the next day when
you're like change crash huge crash now
I got it now I got a rebuild
that's right and faint oh well I'm there
for you anymore yes sir yeah huge crash
and there's no yeah I was listening to
our music the next day and I was like so
that brings up a big question because
you know what does keep there are people
that reach a certain plateau my father
used to always say everybody ends up
where they want to be like we all get to
a point where we've worked hard we've
had goals and we hit them and then some
people just go yeah this is good you
know and then other people go no I want
to go through more pain because getting
to the next level
it's sacrifice it's uncomfortable it's
[ __ ] painful it's getting up off the
couch yeah on a night when now you're
married now you got a kid and now you
got to still get up and go from
Westchester down at the Comedy Cellar in
15 minutes for 20 bucks
and it's the person who does that it
gets to the next level so what is it
because you're one of those people that
is you keep pushing you're on the road
you're doing your show you're you know
you blow industry guys like still some
that can't even help you you guys have
retired so what is it that keeps it is
it fear that it'll go away or is it
terror it's an absolute terror that
everything is gonna go away and then I'm
gonna get fired from here and they're
gonna take with UFC podcast they're
gonna take everything everything is
gonna go you don't feel like a
foundation has been built that you're
like okay that's there but it doesn't
matter it's more of a nation it's not a
foundation it's a pedestal that you
could easily be kicked off of like you I
mean like right it's it's not something
that's solid and it's a stand-up
something that people can't take away
from you yeah and you'd think so sure
but then you lose faith in your stand-up
it happens we all lose faith in our
standup I [ __ ] I don't want to do
this I saw you know whatever it's crazy
stuff people think yeah it moves me
but the stand up is a good point that is
the one thing that it's the girl that
brought you to the dance right and it
still can give you that quick hit of
affirmation acceptance
you've write some new [ __ ] there's still
no hi better than writing new [ __ ] and
having it work and you're in complete
control it's yours it gets you right
back in I can I can be in a spell with
stand up where I'm hearing myself do the
same jokes and I'm looking at the
audience and I don't and you see it
starts to get existential like why are
all these people
yes it's very I'm chicken wings not
talking for an hour while I just keep
talking like I just talked I just made
them laugh and now immediately there's
an expectation that I'm gonna do it
again and again for a [ __ ] hour and
you go into this mindset and then all
you got to do is is sit down to write
some new [ __ ] and even if it's for three
or four minutes during your set it
energy it energizes the whole rest of
the hour yeah it makes you feel really
good it does it and me and Florentine
were talking recently and he's like [ __ ]
my stuff's not working
I just feel flat and what I've done in
the past and I suggested to him is do in
a different order sometimes if you just
do [ __ ] a different order yeah but it
makes you think a little different too
because that [ __ ] get up and go and
then you know where you're at 15 and 40
you're like I want to [ __ ] blow my
brains out there is a guy named John Fox
I love John Fox he was so [ __ ] funny
but he was a hard Boozer yeah and he he
was a Road Dogg he was on the road year
after year for 30 years and every
[ __ ] show for 30 years he walked on
stage the same opening joke to farmer
and her but [ __ ] in a smoke-filled
room and the crowd knows them and they
all yeah and then he would do I forget I
think the chief auction I think that was
the chief walks in or something chief
walks in and he goes what what the hell
is going on here and the guy says well
he had smoke inhalation I was given a
mouth I don't know mouth to mouth noise
smoke inhalation that she should want to
give him mouth-to-mouth resuscitation
how do you think this started yeah
that's it everything but I mean in the
hole that's the set I mean
see why he drank so much because he just
he didn't he was getting nothing out of
the act anyone not at all and and this
and he would but his he was such a gruff
he died a few years ago yeah and he left
me a really sweet message did it start
with that
no I closed it where it was a written
message where he said I'll see you in
heaven it was really sad because he had
cancer I knew he was gonna die
does he know you're going to hell yeah I
thought I did actually say that back
devil horny laughter I may see on the
elevator but yeah and then he would you
would you because his so gruff his thing
was a tow fireman like the way he would
start it was just fun he was funny yeah
there's a funny person he would always
closed with the archibald Marisol
remember that yeah arch AARC gosh I get
ba LD he would do that joke too close
and same thing everything and and I was
I was playing in this uh in this club as
we drove across the country me and my
wife back in 99 we'd moved to LA so he
drove across the country being the the
you know pathetic Road Pig that I am I
set up a get packed into a station wagon
stuff strapped on the roof honey were
stopped by Green Bay Wisconsin nowhere
near and we get up there and and I'm the
headliner and then there's the condo
John Fox had been there and he used to
smoke cigars and he [ __ ] cigar the
[ __ ] out of that place yeah and we go in
and me and my wife I just remember this
I was so glad she came with me because I
think she romanticized what life was
like for me on the road like I was like
we're in a bathrobe
of course you know of course being
catered to right catered your shower
shoes your your terrycloth shower shoes
on from the hotel right yeah taking a
tour of the Louisville Slugger
Louisville and and so we get up there
and we're in the bedroom and it's like
you know stucco with the vertical metal
blinds and you know a bed that's wasn't
a good bed when they bought it 20 years
ago and so we get in a bed and it's
nasty and
throw a move on her and I'm having sex
with her and the feature act is in the
next room and then all sudden we can
hear his bed is squeaking and he's
jerking off to the sound of me and my
wife and she was like we gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here I was like no you
understand this is this is Thursday we
got to do show Sunday and who have you
been a Green Bay Wisconsin I believe I
have I mean there is literally nothing
and it's the worst food and the club
allowed smoking it was like a it was
like a tin warehouse they put chairs in
and everybody and smoked and they were
drunks and it was like you know fat
chicks and Packers jackets terrible gig
I remember when I went back the next
year it was you know so our URL enough
of them though just ease you get there
in one day Thursday night and you're
like oh you [ __ ] and you're
there till Sunday yeah at least at least
Thursday Friday
I hate 6:00 I just did Tampa size
splitters and I love that Club but it's
six shows just leave you Thursday Friday
Saturday Thursday Friday three Saturday
so by the time you get to the third show
on Saturday
you did yeah so that's not your last
show the money is good so you do it for
the money are you sitting there having
no clue what you've said when no I mean
I I don't you can usually I once in a
while you might repeat a joke but you
know by the third show you're okay
because it's not later it's an earlier
shows added so this the reason I did it
because I know that when I started at
eight o'clock I would've been like [ __ ]
you could have made extra mount more
dollars you well you're right here yes
what do you just sit in hotel for free
yeah like but go I would have left
earlier but getting there earlier I had
to take the money did you go see our
friend Mike kalter down there Friday
morning yeah yeah I was doing a show we
did a gym and I went down there about
Kahoot about 516 the row you were on
that's right that was fun man we did
this great roast he was changing his hat
his name from cow head to Mike all right
and we went down and what a lineup was
me you was Florentine on it
I think Florentine Bobby Kelly and and
we went up and Mike
his grandmother was there and and she's
a huge Yankees fan and he's a huge
Yankees fan he told me they both got
Yankees tattoos and so I started talking
about how she got the tattoo on her
vagina
it's got pinstripes in it and and
because guys have been spitting in the
dugout you know Wade Boggs was there
that night
no no way Boggs was there but he
lighting it to meet him he left
I love Wade Boggs I do too yeah I was in
Boston for a lot of years right yeah a
bunch was not he was there at that shook
he was he know Mike knows a lot of those
guys because the Tampa spring training
oh that's right is there Greg are you
more of the push guy I'm gonna push I'm
gonna push I'm gonna push or are you
getting to this place where you're happy
with where you're at you know I pushed
hard I psych him out of the gate hard
yeah like I was one of those guys I'm
sure you were I mean I did it seven
nights a week for the first five years I
did come there was one year I did there
was 13 nights I did endure stand-up in a
year in the whole year it was like yeah
it was like you know 1995 yeah all right
and and we're talking three four five
six sets a night right and and then
going on the road and coming back and
doing it and you know the same thing I
think I've always come from fear and I
started really working on transitioning
out of that about you know maybe four or
five years ago I started meditating and
I just started thinking about how much
of the stuff I've done in my career
because it came at me versus me
proactively saying this is what I want
to do it and I started kind of changing
that mindset I sound like I'm doing a
[ __ ] infomercial right now this is
what it really was a change and with it
I think I don't push as hard because
stuff comes to you that you're supposed
to be doing no more free time I wanted
to start writing more right because I
want it to be home more for my kids of
course the next writing job I'll and
shoots in [ __ ] New York three months
but it's it's such a good credit that I
took edges because it'll get you that
next job in the next job so but you know
I'm not I'm not doing as much stuff
the podcast I feel like I look it down
the road like you get older in this
business and you just you know you're
gonna be put out to pasture I mean
nobody's getting asked me to host
anything anymore and so the podcast fits
dog radio mm-hmm that's not going
anywhere I can't take that they can't
take that away I can say whatever the
[ __ ] I want talk to you you've been on
it a couple times sit down for an hour
with my buddy and talk uninterrupted
with no phones yep that's the greatest
thing in the world
it's amazing and you're jacking a friend
about whatever you want to talk about
and and and again no one's gonna come in
and go look you should leave that
there's no publicist to tell you it is
you and the person that's amazing what
podcasting is done just in terms of
social relationships like you end up
either making or keeping friends yes
because you have these conversations
that you normally would never have
because it's a podcast we have to
actually listen to each other and
concentrate on each other and have a
good conversation that is good enough
that other people would want to listen
to it right and you know and it's a way
to like just you know get caught up
about the comedy world yeah you talk
about where you're at I mean this kind
of conversation so there's that and then
I do the radio show on Sirius XM on
Mondays on Howard's channel and I just
feel like those two things and stand up
or just they're not gonna ever go
anywhere right and then the other stuff
in Hollywood I don't chase as much
anymore yeah I mean I've kind of given
up I'm not gonna be a leading man I
blink too much you know even after
spider-man he but even as a in a comic
way right my role will be limit is what
it is you know what I mean my my doing
what I do is gonna be stand-up or chip
or there's other nonsense it's just
gonna be a peripheral it's not the worst
thing in the world either to not be to
kind of be your careers about you not
about know being an actor yes what I'm
choosing right because it's the stuff I
have control of you create it yourself
yeah I think I I think part of my
unhappiness and a lot of my career was
that it wasn't in my control it was
walking into a room with [ __ ] Bryan
Callen to audition for a role this guy's
you know he's in there he comes out of
the room after a night it he he goes in
ahead of you when he walks out the
casting director has her arm around him
everybody's laughing
changing text messages already and I'm
sitting there gone like I think I know
the lines but I still got the paper yeah
yeah and so it's like I could never
compete with that right and so it just
always felt like it wasn't a fit and now
I feel like so lucky that with this new
media and with having done stand-up for
so long I feel like I'm really control
that and I get out of it what I put into
it
I stopped in and the Denver Comedy Works
I was doing another gig in town and you
didn't see me because you were on stage
and like I wanted to watch i was waiting
people across the field like I'm gonna
go watch Greg for a few minutes and I
just stood in the back I'm gonna watched
you it was really funny man and you were
really you were killing and I remember
this is back before the election and you
said you some joke you did about but I
think while we're waiting for is Donald
to call Hillary a [ __ ] was very funny it
was really thanks man yeah I'd heard
that you were in the back they were like
yeah he came through like an apparition
left yeah I had to leave I'm gonna catch
a few minutes it's funny like when
there's a guy you like working yeah and
you're doing it's like I can just go in
and watch a guy like for a few minutes
yeah yeah I want that place to Denver
Comedy Works man you know what I like
about it is the seats are locked down to
the ground in rows like a Greyhound
station like you have to face the stage
right and you know little tables in
between but it you feel the difference
you feel like they are locked in on you
right and it's like graded seating
towards the back it's like pie-shaped
the bars outside the room it's just it's
kind of like the room like somebody
built a comedy club specifically because
they wanted to have a good comedy club
experience I want it laughter Danny in
the room right right right
and some of these chains they build a
new room and it's got a [ __ ] balcony
here's it here's a newsflash balconies
don't work with comedy not at all or
plays if you see what happen Iligan if
you're in the balcony it means you
bought your tickets late or you're a
[ __ ] yeah and you're not experiencing
the show you're watching the audience
watch the show right terrible no matter
how even a
super close it's still the nosebleeds
right but you're still that guy
yeah the inner balcony is different
because that's a different experience
like a giant but of comedy club balcony
right very difficult yeah yeah to uh
especially when it's empty
yeah but then again the people on the
brown think you sold out that's what's
wrong right no idea no I just did Philly
Philly helium's a great very good club
oh my god you haven't done that in a
while but the ball three his clubs are
good he has that one he has Buffalo when
he has three get like 500 does it really
portland buffalo st. Louis Oh Charlie
good nights in Raleigh North Carolina he
is now owned by him I know that okay and
I want to say this one in Phoenix and he
just told me he's opening another one in
a city I can't announce yeah that guy's
a [ __ ] animal girl but he doesn't
write he builds good [ __ ] rooms and
then he has his existing managers will
fly out and they train the staff of like
here's how to tell people to be quiet
here set a sea front here's how to treat
the comedian's and you get the same
experience at all of his clubs that's
good to know our Grossman is the guy's
yeah the more clubs there are the more
you can like work if things go [ __ ]
south like I'm always expecting you're
fired for radio so I'm like hey if it
happens at least there's like the third
time you've brought it up so it must be
a hot new present or no I'm saying that
it's the only it's the only like
quote-unquote mean there's you know the
podcast is one thing but this is like
it's like having a steady real job right
yeah right weird to be in comedy that
you have a steady with a paycheck coming
in and you get health insurance for
serious no no no no independent
contractor yes yeah no nothing no
insurance to that what happened to and
nobody I mean nobody has health
interfaces again in our business your
independent contractor yeah get your own
health insurance mother friars it
depends how you start I'm not an
independent contractor you know I
created a rift between Jim and not at
all I wouldn't want to work on the to us
[Laughter]
[Music]
they also made it up to Jim by paying
him much much much more than me oh he
makes a lot yeah so I don't know what
Sam makes I don't want to know I didn't
know it Opie made or OPN Anthony when I
worked
I mean are you they made them you don't
make six figures do you yeah what yeah I
figured that you did oh yeah oh I think
you're asked if I'm a seven I do not
have you'd said yes he made seven I'd be
like I have to actually leave and go
talk to seven others yeah yeah of course
yeah you better be yeah all right so
he's so you're making deep six figures
then I don't know what he's big yeah I'm
doing okay yeah I'm happy
am i thrilled before we talk about being
happy
have you ever been warned by the station
about something that you said never
honestly I'm not a hundred percent
convinced they've ever heard a Jim and
Sam show I I'm not either that's being
bad yeah is it bad when you're walking
down the hall and Scott Greenstein puts
out his hand introduces himself
no I'm they don't [ __ ] with us for
content like maybe a couple times Donna
said hey you may want to but it's never
been dickish that's one thing they've
never [ __ ] with us about it yeah oh
don't say that
right then a couple of times it Donna's
asked little things but it's very minor
I've been on for 10 years and I've never
once told what to say or not say which
means they're either really liberal with
language or they just don't listen
yeah yeah I think it's a combination
it's both yeah yeah I think they don't
listen cuz because of that they're like
I don't care what they're talking about
so I know I need to listen there's no
trouble I don't know right that's
basically because then they have
plausible deniability oh I didn't hear
it right but that's why there's so much
middle management they're like I don't
know we hire people because that way if
somebody says something that are not
supposed to we can just ask the the
middle management why didn't you tell me
that they said that thing yeah like
that's all it's a whole job description
you know but I don't even think they're
listening so you still do your podcast
as well why do I do
ChIP chip person podcast haven't over a
year and then the UFC I do their podcast
twice a week right with my friend Matt
we have to get anything I love Matt yeah
yeah he's great um but yeah those are me
chip as my own thing so I could do that
forever but that's not yeah that doesn't
generate revenue it's just fun yeah a
little bit but nothing right nothing to
right now no no no I made a living doing
it
speaking of six figures No
with a decimal point yeah but speaking
of revenue did you hear 0 oj simpson
being the hero of the day I love oj jr.
Gregg did you hear what happened with
that what happened or is he down in
Florida is he in Florida I think Vegas
I think Vegas - he I hope he's in Vegas
I'm gonna I want to meet Oh Jay when I
go to Vegas
just lose your wallet he found
somebody's wallet and he dropped it off
to them Oh Jay he said and this was a
this was a great quote he said that he
knows he also knows he felt sympathy for
the guy because he knows what it's like
to be caught in a stressful situation he
does of course well and also I think he
learned from the waiter who returned Ron
Goldman poetic justice reviews returning
a wallet to some woman step into a
murder yeah and the ex-husband just came
and killed oj terrified he said he
looked up to guys address you know yeah
obviously he's got the driver's license
everything he looked up the guy's
address and found him to give him his
wallet back yeah but I mean if ol Jay is
coming up to your house and you've never
met this guy before oh my god is that
terrible how surreal is it that would be
surreal to open your door no J's there
with your wallet yeah well what do you
think first do you think football player
do you think Naked Gun do you think
murderer if you see if he's at your door
or if you don't recognize them do you
see black guy oh yeah we'll see them all
together it's a father son Holy Ghost
yeah I see I see Hertz rent-a-car I see
yeah I think I see I see
down-on-his-luck oj i see OJ when he was
doing that show juste when he was trying
to a friend yeah
ya know I feel like if I saw Oh J at my
house all the sort of good things would
go away and just be like murderer
there's a murderer here oh my god you
know you don't always like I just went
out to the bathroom and they did a
well-known gentleman who was taking a
photo there was nobody around you want
to say no it was Jesse Jackson yeah
but it was okay he's so famous I'm like
that guy looks like Jesse Jackson and I
stood there and stared at him and he was
talking and I'm like that's that's like
you don't expect to see somebody that
famous in front of you for no reason
yeah and that's probably how it is a no
Jay Simpson comes up here you just
knocks on the door you know Jay yeah
right it's clearly not your white guy
and that's a black guy you don't want to
go how are you and they go no yeah you
don't ever want to I met Ben Vereen once
in the street but it's embarrassing you
don't wanna go hey Ben Vereen and then
all of a sudden it's not Ben Vereen
right I was playing golf with that you
know Jackie Flynn comic Jackie flew yes
he's from Boston you know real like
Boston guy yeah I know who he is and I
think I met him yeah his family they
have the deep-fried but he call the
fried dough at the zeppoles it was a
pleasure they got the zeppole concession
to all the big fairs and events in New
England so like that's where their money
why does that matter but it's just funny
it's great much zeppeli money yeah
absolutely
don't have no everyone frowns on zeppeli
fortunes right now there's six figures
they don't take it seriously and so so
me and Jackie are gonna play golf up in
the valley and OJ Simpson you know got
kicked out of all the private clubs and
so he was relegated to going to public
golf courses to play so we walk up to
the starters gate and it's just me and
Jackie so what they do is they they pair
you up to make a foursome so we check in
and they go are you guys are gonna be
playing with these two guys over there
and we look to our right and it's OJ
Simpson and a friend of his Wow
and I look up to the sky and I think the
comedy gods will be one day my Tonight
Show panel and so so we go I shake his
hand I go nice to meet you shake his
friend Santa nice to meet you and Jackie
spins around he goes no [ __ ] way I'm
playing with a murderer this guy's a
[ __ ] murderer and OJ just walks away
and I was like Jackie I will [ __ ]
kill you
I go can you imagine playing or five
hours alone on the course with OJ and
you don't
bring it up right away no yeah you get
you get to know them everything's cool
and then like on the 11th hole you're
standing over a putt and you just look
up at him and you go oh J so I make this
you gotta tell me I would have been
furious yeah I was furious
why would he do that I think maybe he
just believed it was some people yeah so
I rate like people kill each other all
the time
technically Jackie's probably right like
I'm mad for you because I would want the
picture and my you could buy golf with a
murderer tactically Jackie why can't you
look for something he believed in it's
easy no you could play golf with a
murderer it's just golf
hey you know he earned his freedom
that's right and he's not technically a
murderer that's right before or after
out of jail from Vegas I was before
obviously yes many years ago yeah yeah